the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so here's um here's some code I'm
defining a function function named s Q
and it takes in two parameters I'm
defining a function named f takes in one
parameter and then I'm doing these two
lines the first one is just calling
function SQ and the next one is just
printing the value so let's first see
what nice okay let's work through it so
the first things we see here is to
function definitions right so we don't
currently care about what's inside them
right now because we haven't made a
function call yet so the first thing we
do is we have the function call calc
equal sqf and - okay so inside SQ we're
going to have func and X and func
is going to get mapped to F and X is
going to get mapped to - right so we're
taking the variables in order and
mapping them to those F is func is F and
X is - first thing the function does as
cute is create this variable Y is equal
to x squared so we're going to have Y is
equal to 4 and then we're going to
return func Y so func of Y this is going
to be we're just replacing the
parameters f of 4 right so now this is
another function call we know what F is
I thought this program knows what F is f
is going to be this part right here
which returns x squared okay so in F X
gets mapped to whatever variable we put
in it which in this case is 4
and we're going to return to whoever
called us which is over here 4 squared
which is 16 okay so f of 4 gets replaced
with 16 and F of 4 was up here right
we're just popping out of scopes now so
f of 4 was up here so then this that
line there return func y is going to
return 16 and whoever called us was down
here calc is equal to 16 and then we're
just printing count so 16 was right yay